Oh my God!
ARGATHOS PRISON
TACOMA, WA - UNITED STATES
He's a deadly beast
that can kill you in a second.
-This was the one jobI didn't want.
-Don't try to talk to him!
He's just a walking tree. The size of this man is insane.
How do you get yourself that big, man? Like, how's that even possible?
Oh, is he to be executed? Hanged? That's so scary.
Yeah, he definitely ain't getting to that knot-news.
I bet he's gonna like, tuck down the whole ceiling
or some shit like that...
with his neck.
(Video: I want to tastedefeat.)
God damn, man. Imagine trying to hang him in real life.
I shouldn't be laughing, but...
If this was real life, his neck would just break the rope itself.
Is he dead?
I don't think they ever explained how he actually survives this.
Did he die?
Oh, he actually died.
Like he's just got such a thick neck that it just never reaches his throat.
- No, no. Don't open the...
- Oh, no, don't. Don't go to him...
Don't go to him
It's just so dumb.
It's so stupid. I love it, though.
Only in BAKI. Only in BAKI. Okay.
He's so alive!
Oh my God!
Like, he just pretended to die.
Some real Pillar Men awaken energy here.
Oh, he's dead.
His voice.
So scary.
Yikes.
(Video: make it too easy for me.)
What? What?
Who says that after trying to be-- Like, you've just been hung.
"It's too easy for me. Everything's too easy."
That's how you make a statement. That's how you make a statement.
(Video: If I were to take these tricks)
(and liken them to physical substances,)
(they're impurities.)
Oh, this scene.
(Video: This kind of chatter is too.)
Oh, I love this fight. This fight's so fun.
I haven't actually seen this fight yet.
Oh, he got thrown away.
That old man is about to kick his ass for sure.
Yujiro, the biggest Chad in the anime.
Oh, I need to catch up with Season 2.
Okay, but don't hit the old man.
I don't know.
Come on, dude, stand for yourself.
Okay, I don't know what this fight is.
I feel like if you're watching this out of context,
this would be so weird and not make any sense
why is this Chad monster destroying this old man.
This is some of the thickest anime boys I've ever seen.
I was only using 10 percent of my energy.
(Video: I'm not exerting enough strength?)
(Come.)
- Damn.
- Oh, damn, man. Goddamn.
That dude really likes getting hit in the face.
And of course the old man somehow destroys the walking monster.
That's it. That's it.
(Video: Everything else...)
(Everything else is...)
(Video: an impurity.)
I also kick my enemies off the wall when I fight them, naturally.
Yeah, this dude like he's like 160 years old and he somehow, like survives.
That wall clearly isn't doing anything to the old man.
He has the single most ugliest face in anime
but you can't help but love him just because how confident he is.
Get him.
No, I don't know why every time I watch a BAKI fight,
I'm always surprised of how much damage someone can take.
(Video: Baki.)
(You seem absurdly happy.)
I'm also absurdly happy. This is fun.
Bro, how are you not dead? You're like 160 years old.
And you took a kick from Yujiro.
I don't know the context of this fight.
But I'm pretty sure if I did know the context, it would make a lick of difference.
I know the context of this clip and it still is dumb.
Like I still... It still is stupid.
But it's so good, trust me.
It's so dumb but I love it.
It's so absurd.
How can you not love this?
(Video: What remains is the fact
that I was protected by this man!)
Oh, we're going back in time. Okay.
Oh, I think we skipped to another fight.
Retsu Kaioh has to be the best character in this.
The music!
Oh, it's some Naruto-esque music. I'm liking it.
Oh, the music, how fitting.
I don't know what happens here.
Wait. What?
What?
Oh, that dude's...
Oh, it's the ripple.
Outrun the bike, bro.
Wait. How did that guy not fly forward?
That's not how inertia works.
(Video: Apologies! My name is Retsu.)
That is how physics works. I can confirm that.
It's how they work. What?
Or just stop it with your bare hand.
You can do that, too.
He's so kind.
It's an appropriate reaction to that.
I'm sure he's gonna walk on water.
It's only like, a what, a 50-meter jump? He can do it.
You have no other choice. Of course.
It's more than 10 meters.
Oh, how is he gonna cross?
Oh, how is he gonna cross this?
Definitely make me laugh.
(Video: It won't be a problem for about 15 meters!)
How do I not remember this? This is like one of the dumbest things ever.
Come on, bro. You got it.
At first...
At first I thought he was gonna jump over.
This is so much better.
This is actually where all the animation budget went as well, actually.
I don't know if you know.
Oh, I love BAKI so much, man.
Dude like...
straight up jump 50 feet.
You could definitely jump that river.
I really like anime because sometimes they don't make sense but...
Why don't you swim?
Hey, yo. You made it. You're good, son.
Trust me that there is more insane scenes than this. Believe it or not.